hey vegan turn around I'm talking to you
take those off you don't eat meat and
that's fine but stop eating these Topher
keys every Thanksgiving
they don't look or taste like real
Turkey but you're in luck the makers of
the meat free impossible burger have now
created a meat-free
impossible turkey no meat it's not a
gross ball of brown it's shaped like a
normal turkey how do we do it easy first
we take a genuine real authentic turkey
shaped turkey then we cover it in the
completely vegan impossible meat then we
wrap it then we sell it then you buy it
cook it eat it easy it will look so
delicious like real Turkey just don't
cut too deep when you're carving it just
the outside part just get the outside
that's right whoa careful okay good hey
I'm drumstick
now just the outside not the inside
completely vegan Happy Thanksgiving and
now you're done throw that out no meat
good job
okay put them back on good vegan
impossible turkey looks real tastes fine
don't need the inside part
[Applause]